[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge ein hof am
see für markus silvia und yu na die burg
suchen die ruhe in schweden und
vermieten ferienhäuser viva méxico
stefano lott jonn stefano navarrete zog
es in die karibik im land des tequila
wittern sie ihre chance und familie
zogaj möchte sich in südafrika neu
erfinden
sie eröffnen eine lodge
[Musik]
lange winterabende ins nocebo auf dem
hof von kurz zeit für jonas gute nacht
ritual
[Musik]
mein gemacht hatte markus immer gerade
so wie sich sehr gut acht monate ist
töchterchen ja schon
sie hat den alltag von buchs völlig
umgekrempelt
[Musik]
markus sieht seine tochter nur am abend
und am wochenende
er arbeitet auf einer baustelle in lima
b
[Musik]
yuma bekommt ihre ersten zähne doch
klimt ist etwas mit dem einschlafen
[Musik]
gerade erst waren sie in ihre rollen als
gastgeber hinein gewachsen da veränderte
sich das leben der beiden noch einmal
völlig für papa markus und mama silvia
seit der experte in der letzten folge
legten die pumps den sommer über mit
gästen auf ihrem hof die ferienhäuser
waren ausgebucht und töchterchen jona
ist da in mexiko wollten die stephanus
mehr
sie trennten sich von onkel fernando sie
suchten sich einen neuen
geschäftspartner und investieren einen
teil ihres kapitals in zwei
luxuswohnungen torkreis fanden in
südafrika endlich ihr haus vier
gästezimmer und ein familien cottage
wollen sie nun vernichten
sie sind noch gar nicht richtig
angezogen
da tauchen die ersten probleme auf
[Musik]
leicht und handlich das teil aber die
bekannten haben es extra organisiert für
das einweihungsfest morgen bei talk die
türkei eröffnen ihre lose endlich immer
wieder müssen sie sich neu orientieren
und verschiedene hindernisse überwinden
den gästezimmern fehlen noch die
vordächer
[Musik]
naja ob wir ganz gefächert lebens
niemals komplett aus vier monate lang
haben sie alles hergerichtet
sie haben das wohnhaus und die
gästezimmer neu gestrichen den
wasserschaden repariert die
wasserinstallationen erneuert und das
bad renoviert hat probleme mit dem
vordach fast sagen jetzt richtig
prioritäten setzen
im großen ganzen fertig sie aber das ist
mein tv mit der project oder und
vertreiben her da wird es immer
irgendwie es aber nicht fertig ist und
verlängert das ist okay so
ein fortlaufendes projekt das canon
drucker ist seit sie ihr
südafrikanisches abenteuer begonnen
haben
[Musik]
in schweden macht sich marcus burg auf
den weg zur arbeit
er muss zusätzlich geld verdienen
die mieteinnahmen aus den beiden
ferienhäusern reichen der jungen familie
noch nicht zum überleben
seit einem halben jahr job markus in
einem erlebnispark als mahner der
vorbesitzer ihres rufes hat ihm die
arbeit vermittelt was ist so machen und
dann hätte zuständige schaffen oder
pflegeheims gestrichen hätte wenn die
oma dem feld auf der baustelle und dann
hätte er exakt uhr
das ist zwar in china mich noch mal her
aber auch sega der cannes rolle neben
dem erlebnispark astrid lindgrens welt
werden an die 30 kleine holzhäuser für
touristen gebaut
markus ist nicht fest angestellt wie
viele seiner kollegen arbeitet er
selbständig fünf tage in der woche wird
auf der baustelle gebraucht
fürs streichen bekommt er etwas mehr als
300 franken pro tag
was wenn ich jetzt hier auf fang gemacht
hat dann müsste ich ganz schöne maschine
investieren und so habe jetzt einfach
die möglichkeit schaffe geld verdiene
und mit dem geld kann immer noch die
maschine kaufen wo sie halt bruch und es
wäre so hat die variante wollte fuß ihn
jetzt bringen weil die hier ja auch
china hin dass wir dann halt mal vom ohr
auf der schiene wechseln kann
ich war bisher zu mit passiert
[Musik]
der ruf am see im winterschlaf
die ferienhäuser sind nur noch
gelegentlich vermietet silvia nimmt sich
die zeit und kümmert sich voll und ganz
um jona
[Musik]
in der schweiz verkaufte sie zuletzt
holzhäuser in snuko managte sie von
anfang an den hof jetzt gibt die kleine
jona den takt an
[Musik]
ich bin froh dass diese gut mitgemacht
dass sie mir mein geschafft
[Gelächter]
juni ist die nächte waren die zeit lang
besonders beschwerlich
[Musik]
die drei bis viermal vom häuser
verkaufen in der schweiz auf den hof am
see und jetzt auch noch mutter und
hausfrau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weit weg vom meer und von den touristen
stefano navarrete ist umgezogen
nur eine zwischenstation auf dem weg zum
big business
seit ein paar monaten hat es sich hier
eingerichtet
zusammen mit seiner verlobten lässig
kollege stefano lotti ist vorübergehend
bei den beiden eingezogen wenn wir bei
die wohnung gekauft hat und mit jetzt
dir das hus provisorischer nützen sich
mit leslie kongo und angola und das
treffen selbst ein bisschen kleiner wird
wahrscheinlich league auf die wahlliste
ca
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wesley ist zuständig für das frühstück
so ist es in ihrer familie tradition
besucht zwinge sie macht's geraden und
darum wie es mir sagen also mit
institute sind wir ins nächste
ganz im gegenteil nur die kaum in erster
linie auto leslie hat sich entschieden
mit stefano zusammenzuziehen
obwohl sie nur verlobt sind ist es mir
egal
mit leslie taucht stephan rein ins
gemütliche leben nie eine paarbeziehung
stefano genießt was ihm sein onkel
fernando durch die einwanderung
ermöglicht hat
[Musik]
am kap ist es soweit
in ein paar stunden kommen die gäste zum
fest
dann präsentieren talk heiß ihre not
sind und hilfe von gute bekannte von
räumen der macht der alte wie pfizer so
dass ich alles wieder verwertet und vor
allem hätte wahnsinns für mitarbeiter
oder wirklich aus einem township sollte
und die erlernt das ganze konzept
sondern halt mal ein anderer stoff
dieser
doris fährt noch mal los in den zimmern
fehlt noch etwas wichtiges thema und
doris bauen beharrlich weiter an ihrem
ganz persönlichen traum von afrika
stück für stück haben sie dafür
zusammengetragen
die fundstücke bekommen in der lodge ein
zweites leben
doris hat es geschafft die zimmer
könnten für die präsentation perfekt
werden das auto ist voller fotoleinwände
bilder die die türkei auf ihren reisen
selber geschossen haben
jedes von ihnen wird zum herzstück eines
zimmers und elefant da und die anderen
links und anstelle und dann werde ich
entscheiden weil bei ihm zusammen
stellen zeigt sich ein teil der
leinwände fehlt noch
aber wie gesagt das sei wie fertig
das hat mich schon die ganze linie sind
nicht gemacht also die große mal wieder
die großen ein neues großer manier
braucht es ist größer als die anderen
damit im elephant und ein negativer
saldo selbst wenn man einmal
ausgerechnet das lieblingsfoto scheint
nicht da zu sein scheinen damit ich was
gerne geholt das ist die andere forscher
telefon
ja frau gabriele französischen hof
ja denn zimmersafe endlich linie
das ist eine dieser partie zwischen vsc
tisch zieht
markey machen elefant gut alles gut
[Musik]
einmal in der woche ist yu na bei den
nachbarn nachbarin lisa passt auf die
kleine auf ihre eigenen enkel wohnen
weit weg
umso mehr genießt sie die zeit mit jona
[Musik]
ein paar freie stunden für markus und
sie hier
also sich eigentlich so dass mehrere
nachbarn ist auch ob das sinn macht
würden sie den schwedischen brauche das
einfach integriert
zu herrn sich beruf trennen können
[Musik]
dieburg haben einen festen termin in
weimar will
die freien stunden nutzen sie für einen
sprachkurs schwedisch für einwanderer in
der schweiz hatten sie bereits einige
lektionen genommen
denn kurs bietet die gemeinde gratis an
[Musik]
am anfang sind alle immer ein liegt
gemeinsam singen dass es sehr beliebt in
schweden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jeder erhält eine aufgabe und soll sie
im zweierteam bearbeiten
anschließend halten sie einen kleinen
vortrag auf schwedisch
das trieb sich ich mag sich wohlfühlen
gedeihen
der auftrag für markus was wir bewusst
der bitte von de facto mir internet
intel hatte ok ok fis gepostet werden
die karten fiskus geht da war ich fix
gewalt ab dazu musste ich von hinten
[Gelächter]
die bayern machen sich gut auf der
schulbank und ihr schwedisch wird immer
besser
[Musik]
auf der farm ist das wichtigste erledigt
jetzt wird die lodge eingeweiht
mit einem ritual dass ich da wirklich
gerne schweiz zusammen sein klub moderne
kulig der weihrauch soll die guten
geister wecken
[Musik]
und wenn es nicht wirkt dann riecht es
wenigstens gut
[Musik]
für mich ist es auch einen eigenen
auftritt bringe alles was schätzt wecken
und dass ich große spirituelle sache und
ich hab sind ist es schwer gefallen
starteten damals
[Musik]
die ersten fest gäste trudeln ein
in der neuen heimat haben sich talker
ist bereits ein kleines netzwerk
aufgebaut
sie haben bekannte freunde handwerker
eingeladen und alle die auch nicht
mitgeholfen haben zwei offen und die
arbeiten sind noch nicht da fehlt jemand
gesagt gucken weggucken stellwerk
travelers watch haben sie ihr gästehaus
getauft einer lodge die ihre persönliche
handschrift tragen soll
[Musik]
gemeinsam ins ziel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
something that s it vision in front
office for sale on time you just the
opening party letzter gedanke war alles
passiert ist ein moment wo man von mir
ja noch nie kein totales wirklich gute
freunde sind dann ist das einfach ein
emotionaler tag
aber absolut positiv
das fest ist ein voller erfolg
ab sofort warten vier doppelzimmer und
ein familien cottage auf zahlen der
gäste
[Applaus]
[Musik]
32 grad sonnenschein und wochenende in
der karibik
da arbeitet bei den stefanos nur das
geld eine zeit lang haben sie mit onkel
fernando ihr kapital investiert jetzt
geschäften sie auf eigene rechnung
zusammen mit ihren neuen business
partner marco und seiner familie
schippern sie raus aufs meer zur isla
mujeres einen beliebten ausflugsziel
[Musik]
einkaufen und die welt unter wasser
genießen aber ohne schwimmhilfe geht
nichts
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sich treiben lassen abschalten
in der schweiz waren sie chefs einer
personalagentur und hatten dafür kaum
zeit
kleins steuer erwischt
die rechte
in mexiko kommen die auswanderer voll
auf ihre kosten
[Musik]
snuko ist er sehe jetzt vollständig
zugefroren
seit einigen wochen herrscht hier
dauerfrost
markus probiert sich im pimpl fiscal
zwischen sein neues hobby
irgendwie ist es schön ruhig mal
gemütlich und wenn man halt einen
fischfang dann ist es halt ja ich was
anderes an fisch jemand im sommer kauft
oder halt gras vor rund einem jahr haben
die pumps die schweiz hinter sich
gelassen
da glaube ich bei uns wegen spezieller
das gros ältere teile und unsere
großeltern sitze halten deutschland oder
in der schweiz
denn anders wäre halb erwarb und so 134
passte so was ihm jetzt gab es schöne
sache
webbs haben ihre laute drei zimmer
wohnung an der bahnstrecke aufgegeben
ihre verwandten und freunde in der
schweiz zurück gelassen
silvia und markus hätten den
familienbetrieb der eltern übernehmen
sollen
sie verzichteten darauf für die eltern
war das damals eine große enttäuschung
eine thront wir sind sehr glücklich aber
es ist glaube ich muss drei wochen
reicht nicht mehr
deshalb ist die kleine schwedische
familie hat ihren plan konsequent
verfolgt das geschäft mit den gästen und
die familie können nun weiter wachsen
[Musik]
in südafrika beseitigt tibor die letzten
spuren von einweihungsfest ist praktisch
wenn man das später liegt bisher haben
die schweizer mit ihrer lodge noch
nichts eingenommen
trotzdem braucht es schon mitarbeiter
gibson und francis haben die begehrten
jobs bekommen und die beiden
angestellten der vorbesitzer haben talk
heiß übernommen
stanley und christa
[Musik]
christa hat sich gut eingearbeitet
aber stanley macht den talk heiß
kopfzerbrechen ästhetischen prinzip
letzte woche ja ich glaube ein
friedliches sie halbseitig schwindlig
und den start gegangen und die schau am
samstag in coburg ist wir brauchen jede
jetzt zur miete von politischer und
menschlicher klinik deutliche gründete
rische eltern mit soße um die
vergangenheit oder in welcher klinik aus
mit dem logisch aber das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich da die arbeitslosigkeit ist
hoch in südafrika gute jobs sind rar
aber wenn sie nichts von stanley hören
werden sie wohl nach einer anderen
lösung suchen müssen
community den schrieb shuttle mit den
dokumenten beschäftigen
aber wir leben halt irgendwas wenigstens
inneren aber dann nicht irgendwann schon
so relativ schlecht sind und wer stellt
zwei andere herrscher war krank sind und
fit in ihrem alltag begegnen die
auswanderer immer wieder den
widersprüchen dieses landes eine lösung
zu finden die für stanley und auch für
die topf passt ist fast nicht möglich
[Musik]
auch bei der bootstour die geschäfte mit
den immobilien bleiben bei den stephanus
immer im eck
dr
hey leute quanta costa
[Musik]
erst acht monate hier schon das nächste
ziel vor augen
luxus apartments auf einer insel
die rettung
jawohl special
wenn ich wirklich spezielle
nicht nur zu decken
die idee vom großen geld
sie ist in mexiko präsenter denn je
[Musik]
zfs auf stippvisite in der schweiz und
gleich wieder mitten drin in der
flughafen hektik auf dem hof am see sind
im moment keine feriengäste eine gute
gelegenheit für ein familientreffen
[Musik]
vater theo vieles vor einem jahr
besonders schwer seine tochter gehen zu
lassen
die großmutter beatrice im glück
[Musik]
ein frühsommertag in südafrika
familie türkei hat sich auf ihrer farm
in namibia eingerichtet in einer neuen
vielleicht auch ungewissen zukunft aber
auf jeden fall raus aus dem trott in der
schweiz
die erste schwere zeit in der schule hat
oracle gut überstanden und ihren weg
gefunden zeige ich es eigentlich dass
man so auch sowie die beste freundin hat
aber den ganzen anderen aber so gut sind
und ja ich bin auch mika fühlt sich
daheim
er hat ganz schnell englisch gelernt im
hintergrund stürzt sich doris ins
networking und tibor hat den raum der
für das frühstück vorgesehen war
zur fahrradwerkstatt umfunktioniert
jetzt hat er viel platz um seine passion
auszuleben ja jetzt in letzter zeit
überhaupt wenn wir zum beispiel vor
überhaupt nimmt das sehr sehr schade
aber das wird sich wieder ein dabei
neben dem lodge betrieb wollen die talk
heiß auf velos vermieten und
individuelle touren anbieten
tja der businessplan schrieb die sagen
noch vor dass wir jetzt wieder 2018
uenze bereits mit geld verdienen das
klar die zimmer stehen bereit
und die ersten gäste rollen an
[Applaus]
wir sind freunde und da könnte ganz
genau
ein gutes jahr haben türkeis gebraucht
beharrlich glaubten sie an ihr projekt
[Musik]
von steckborn am bodensee ans kap in
südafrika sie wollten sich neu erfinden
ich habe sicher gefunden das sie aus dem
heim statt untergang völlig er genau
mich völlig neu entdecken
natürlich auf und absatzkrise hahn und
robinie behalten wer bin ich und das
zeigt eine befragung nachschub und genau
da ist aber davos ist so wertvoll machen
merkel geht seine chance bekommen
business member machen die chance sich
an geraten die geschichte der türkei es
geht weiter und bringt immer wieder
neues ins leben der auswanderer
[Musik]
schütz im kanton luzern erster großer
familie dort wiedersehen mit kleinen
zuwachs am richtigen ort und tänze
folgerichtige entscheidung und der
richtige schritt und so und da haben wir
auch nie wegen des managers stimmt es
ist auch so dass mir extrem schön die
lebensqualität und in schweden schätze
die video und die ruhe und die natur und
das hat die schweiz auch erste
heimgegangen mir kein silber am
arbeitsplatz wie gesagt das ganze zu
einheimischen also das ist so geheim ist
natürlich die fans ist das was man
schwitzt nicht vermisst
[Musik]
auswandern die einen suchen die ruhe die
anderen das abenteuer
[Musik]
am anfang stand bei allen ein großer
traum
der wunsch von einem anderen leben in
der ferne
hinter dem horizont erhofften sie sich
das glück oder zumindest das schnelle
geld
die schnitte im bereich service komplett
unsere chance in der schweiz
es hat der mann die tankstelle zum
blühen die kennengelernt weil sony der
noch viele viele schwierige cvat &
programm haben die ordnungspolitisches
perfektes land
ich bin nicht ganz perfekt frage santos
es klappt mit schlacht gewonnen
jeder zieht besondere nicht weil ich
mich unwohl fühlt als meine faulheit
sondern weiter salz traum von der
qualifikation erfüllt damit ob das
paradies bleiben
[Musik]
zehn jahre auf und davon
zehn jahre geschichten rund ums aus
anderen brechen auch sie auf ins
abenteuer
dann melden sie sich bei uns schreiben
sie an den auswandern bessere vom ca
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nächste woche bei auf und davon
sagen wir buy belassen wir erzählen die
geschichte von alleen und fred müller
auf dem jura die ihr glück in kanada
suchen nach kairo zieht es schon in
china er möchte dort die ägypterin
empire solimann heiraten und die familie
leipzig wandert nach frankreich in die
ungarn aus und lebt dort mit ihren
tieren in der freien natur
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge